but first breaking tonight senior law
enforcement officials telling NBC news
that there is growing frustration inside
the FBI as they finish the bulk of their
work on the hunter Biden case over a
year ago and reportedly the IRS finished
its part of the investigation more than
a year ago as well now remember the
Washington Post had previously reported
that there was enough evidence
discovered to charge Hunter Biden with
tax crimes and a false statement related
to a gun purchase now this comes out on
the heels of another bombshell report
that could be the straw that broke
Biden's back a whistleblower special
agent from the IRS has come forward to
allege that Joe Biden was getting
special treatment in special protection
in the agency's investigation of his son
Hunter the whistleblower's lawyer
appeared on Special Report tonight
he's not a political person he's not a
social media person he's not coming here
with a political agenda he is spotted
and observed things that are done
differently in in this particular matter
which I can't identify
and he wants to talk about them and he
believes that they were influenced by
politics
B because because Joe has sworn all
along that there's no there there now
remember these are the so-called
Defenders of democracy remember that but
in the end of course they're trashing
our Democratic systems and laying waste
to our justice system all for their own
political ends now it's gotten so bad
that the Legacy Media that's always
circled the wagons for the Biden family
well they're actually covering the story
here's CBS
an attorney for an IRS supervisor sent a
letter to lawmakers today asking for
whistleblower protection saying his
client has information that suggests the
investigation is being improperly
influenced by quote preferential
treatment and politics
is the old mule so injured that even the
vultures at CNN
decided to swoop down for their little
bit of Flesh now it's clear that there's
an IRS agent who is apparently involved
in the case who wants to go to Congress
and share what he believes are
allegations of mishandling and politics
at play here
now the White House was obviously
rattled enough to release a hastily
written statement of course dismissing
the whistleblowers allegations now with
the perfunctory Assurance of course that
the hunter Biden investigation will
remain free from any political
interference and that the doj is
handling it independently
well maybe that's the issue because late
tonight the New York Post reported that
attorney general Merritt Garland himself
is the senior officials cited in the
whistleblowers letter if true
that would contradict testimony that
Garland himself delivered under oath
last month
I promised to leave the manor of Hunter
Biden in the hands of the U.S attorney
for the District of Delaware I have
pledged not to interfere with that
investigation and I have carried through
on my pledge
so does the nation's top lawyer need a
lawyer
or something else they're sweating about
tonight uh one news that xcia director
Mike Morrell had become a problem for
Biden it turns out that he testified
under oath that it was the Biden
campaign itself that was behind that
letter that he and 50 other former Intel
officials released that claimed remember
falsely that information from Hunter
Biden's laptop ah was just Russian
disinformation
Congressman Jordan Jim Jordan asked well
what was the intent of the statement and
Morel answered one intent was to you
know share our concern with the American
people that the Russians were playing on
this issue and two
it was to help vice president the vice
president
chairman Jordan then says you wanted to
help the vice president why
the answer
because I wanted him to win the election
and then it got worse when Morel said
that current Secretary of State Anthony
blinken was the one who spearheaded the
letter
now remember it's never just about
Hunter
in the end it's always about the big guy
joining me now is house Judiciary
Committee chairman Jim Jordan
Congressman you've been very methodical
about this investigation we're going to
get to Morrell's testimony
um but is it worth asking
first whether the Attorney General
himself
may be in some legal Jeopardy here on
the question of obstruction of justice
given what we learned from NBC News and
others tonight
yeah we'll have to see what we do know
uh Laura is what you said this has been
political from the get-go clear back to
the morel situation when the story came
out on October 14th 2020 about the Biden
business operation and was then Vice
President Joe Biden involved there was
some concern that that he was and then
quickly it turns in this political
operation that that letter that became
the basis for suppressing the story and
keeping it from the American people just
days before the most important election
we have election for President United
States so understand what happened Laura
the 14th to post says the story the 17th
Tony blanken Senior advisor to the Biden
campaign current Secretary of State
contacts Mike Morrell gets him
interested in this Mike Morrell looks at
it the next day organizes on the 18th
all these other people to sign the
letter the 19th the letter goes out and
then on the 22nd the reason Mike Morrell
said he did the letter was he thought
president Trump would bring the issue up
during that debate on the 22nd of
October and of course he did and they
wanted some statement that Joe Biden
could use because as Mr Morrell said
they wanted him to win yeah what happens
on the 22nd Joe Biden brings it up and
it and then after that debate here's the
kicker Steve roschetti chair of the
Biden campaign calls up Mike Morrell and
thanks him for doing it all it was a
total political operation and the most
important fact is Laura it was false it
wasn't Russian disinformation the laptop
story looks to be true well just so
people remember what happened because
there are a lot of facts flying around
here tonight this was during the 2020
debate and and this is what Congressman
Jordan is referring to Biden actually
referencing this letter that we now know
a lot more about watch
there are 50 former National
Intelligence folks who said that what
this he's accusing me of is a Russian
plan you mean the laptop is now another
Russia Russia Russia hoax that's exactly
what this is exactly what this is where
he's going the last laptop is Russia
oh Congressman Donald Trump was right
was he not this is ridiculous he sure
was it sure was but the way the the uh
Vice then Vice President Biden did it
was he made it seem like it was organic
and understand it was it was
choreographed all the way and understand
this too it wasn't just their names on
that letter on that statement it was
their names and their title former head
of odni former CIA director that gave it
that gave it this this feeling and this
impression that it was yeah this
impromotive that it was accurate when it
wasn't and that's the scariest thing of
all and that that letter became the
basis for keeping this information from
the American people and the other thing
that was important we learned in that
deposition with Mr Morrell is they were
even Mr Morrell was even trying to
direct who the Biden campaign told him
who to get this to in the media it was
that coordinated oh that's a scary no
well they're all very you know what it
reminds me of Congressman the letter
that was uh choreographed for the
article that was choreographed about the
origins of coven remember fauci and
Collins all those guys got on that
calling okay we're going to put it out
there and then the media runs with it
it's the same game they run this game
you know I don't know how many times a
year but they run it consistently when
it's a when it's a political uh question
that they want to resolve in their favor
if this happens time
you're right just let the American
people decide who we want representing
us who we want leading us who we want to
elect into office quit trying to put
your finger on the scale just out of it
let We the People decide now I want to
get to this IRS whistleblower question
here was the White House on this today
the president respects the rule of law
uh and and the independence of the
Department of Justice he believes that's
what they should be in this
Administration we believe that it should
be independent so I'm not going to go
beyond that department of justice will
certainly deal with this issue
Congressman
um
are they letting Garland kind of twist
in the wind out there
you know it's hard to say but we do look
forward to communicating with this uh
with this whistleblower and seeing what
he has to say the the timeline has been
so long and they've had this they've had
the laptop since since 2019 they had the
laptop before they even the previous
Subs you were talking about and the
laptop before they even did this this
put this statement together for goodness
sake so um we do look forward to talking
this individual working with his
attorney and we will begin that process
and make sure that we uh we get a chance
to visit with him and see what he has to
say right we don't want to jump to
conclusions because that's what the
Democrats do but the facts speak for
themselves at some point and Congressman
thank you for all you're doing hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else